thanks everybody for coming out to my
talk my name is Michael Becker I work on
the data ninjas team at a weber aweber
is an email service provider located
just outside of Philadelphia and I'm all
I'm also the founder of the data Philly
meet up and we have over 800 members so
working on the the damn team at a Weber
I've introduced several predictive
algorithms into our application and my
co-workers think that I'm some sort of
mass superhero reading scholarly papers
by day and fighting crime by nights but
the truth is much more sinister so
fortunately for me I don't have to be a
genius to look like a superhero I just
have to use Python well I'll cover some
math in this talk I'll mainly just be
keeping things high level okay so what
will I be covering today so to start off
I'll define what is data science I'll
teach you the awesome data science
process I'll demonstrate how to create a
custom web scraping but I'll convert the
data to plain text I'll explore the data
using pandas seaborne and scikit-learn
and finally I'll walk you through
creating a predictive model using
scikit-learn
so what is data science there's a lot of
disagreement on the subject but I like
this Venn diagram that was created by
Drew Conway which gives us a good high
level overview of what skills are
involved in data science so he Conway
argues that at a minimum you need these
three main skills to be a good data
scientist hacking skills math and
statistics and substantive expertise so
in the in the hacking in the hacking
circle over here he includes things like
manipulating text files at the command
line and thinking algorithmically in the
the math and statistics section I think
is pretty straightforward you need to
know math and probably statistics but
drew argues that these two on their own
are not enough that you also need to
understand your data you need domain
knowledge and expertise so i'm not sure
if it was a Hillary Mason who first
coined the term awesome but that's
certainly who I learned it from awesome
is a typical data science process
followed by many data scientists so
let's break it down obtained is pretty
straightforward to do data science you
first need data not all data is going to
be easy to access so be prepared to
through some hoops to obtain your data
set okay so you have your data set now
what if you're lucky your data will be
well structured and easily possible but
in reality it's really that simple messy
did is the norm not the exception but
don't panic scrubbing your data is just
another part of the job get the most out
of your data set you need to understand
it this is where the Explorer step comes
in this can be as simple as looking at
your raw data in a text editor or as
advanced as running machine learning
algorithms on your data sometimes you
want to predict the future using your
data this is usually where a machine
learning comes into the picture so the
goal here is to maximize your predictive
power
by minimizing the level of error and a
model isn't useful on its own and so
this is where the interpret step comes
in often while interpreting the results
of your model you'll identify areas for
improvement which will allow you to
iterate and improve on it so even a bad
model can lead to some useful insights
so in this talk I'm going to walk you
through the awesome process by building
a language classification algorithm from
scratch a language classification
algorithm will predict the language of
some text so for example if you might
give it the text yada yada yada and it
would classify this as English
presumably so language classification
can be useful on its own for example
I've actually used this algorithm that
I'm going to be presenting to you guys
today to break down a Weber's customers
by the language that they use in the
emails that are that they send and it
can also be a useful pre-processing step
so for example Google likely uses it to
automatically detect the what language
that you're typing into Google Translate
and Google Chrome probably uses it to
detect the language of the web pages
your viewing so step one of the awesome
process is to obtain the data in the
case of our language classification
model we need to we need text in a bunch
of different languages fortunately
wikipedia has an abundant supply of this
data there there Wikipedia data sets
available online but that's not much fun
let's build our own so to start off I
grabbed a list of our early page views
from this pick the dumpster wiki
wikimedia org and i wrote some scripts
to aggregate this data for several
months and then i compiled a list of the
top articles / language
next I use the special export page for
each Wikipedia to export the pages that
I want and this task was made trivially
scriptable via the use of the copy as
curl command in the chrome developer
tools and then I also found this other
awesome library called uncurl and so you
you give it like the output of the
copyist curl and it turns it into a
Python request module code so this is
you can literally run this code and it
will make the same st. croix request and
then you know you make some minor
modifications to it to like parameterize
some of the things and you have an
instant Python bot alright so now that
we've obtained our data the second step
is to scrub it the dumps from Wikipedia
are in XML format so we'll need to pull
the articles out of the XML luckily I
didn't really have to write any code for
this there's some Python code that
already does this called Wikipedia
extractor and it produces output that
books looks like XML but it's not not
not actually XML so I I spent some time
trying to figure out if I could fix the
code but it was a bit ugly so rather
than trying trying to fix the their code
I just wrote a simple regular expression
to parse out the the data that I needed
all right so our date is scrubbed now
it's time to explore to start off I
counted the number of times each
character occurs in each language and
then I grabbed the top two thousand from
each of them
so after I ran this code I have a list
of dictionaries that makes it easy to
load into a pandas dataframe and you can
think of a data frame as a mix between
an Excel spreadsheet and a sequel
database but it's Python so the first
thing I did once I load it into a pandas
dataframe was I calculated the
percentages from our raw letter accounts
so we can do this using the div method
and then we can add these percentages as
columns to a new Dana frame by using the
the joint method and if you're using
pandas inside of ipython notebook you
can get and easily you can easily
display the contents for inspection
alright so now let's use two
unsupervised machine learning techniques
to visualize our data there's a lot
going on here so let's break it down a
little bit first we run the k-means
clustering algorithm on our letter
percentages and what kate means does is
it automatically groups your data
together based on similarity next we run
an algorithm called principal component
analysis and we're using PCA here to
reduce our number of columns from 10,000
to two and the reason for this will
become clear in the next slide finally
we plot the results and since our data
only has two dimensions since we ran PCA
on it it's really easy to plot and in
this in this scatter plot here the color
of each point corresponds to the cluster
that it's in and we can see that with
four clusters there's a pretty clear
separation like for example like I could
draw a line here and it's pretty obvious
that these all are going to be on this
side and these are all going to be on
that side
and and for each of these it's pretty
easy to draw Joel just a line to
separate them but one thing I noticed
right away was that when the data like
this there's some clear outliers so I
dug into the the data a little bit and
it basically what i found was that most
of these lengths to use their own unique
character sets which is why they're way
out here in nowheres land all right
another way that we can kind of dig into
this data is we can use the pairwise
distances function from scikit-learn and
we can use that to find the languages
that are most similar so this function
pairwise distances calculates the
Euclidean distance between each pair of
points the smaller the distance the more
similar the data points are so we can
see that the most similar languages are
are in our first cluster cluster zero
and creation serbo-croatian and bosnian
are the most similar followed by
indonesian and mal a danish and
norwegian and English and Scots some of
these really similar languages will
probably be useful for us later on when
we're training a classifier to help
benchmark it finally a seaborne which is
a graphing library that's built on top
of matplotlib is a is really awesome it
has a bunch of really awesome graphs
built in and they're really easy to use
and so we can use we can use some of
these these graphs to visualize the
similarity of our languages here we have
what's called a violin plot and it's
similar to a box plot if you've ever
seen them but basically it you get the
distribution of the letter frequencies
in addition to the 25th 50th and 75th
percentiles so here we can see like for
example that arabic and egyptian arabic
are really similar
so seaborne also has a ton of other
awesome graphs built-in and here's just
a few other examples they actually
released a new version yesterday I think
and I saw that they added some cool
cartography based plots and there's some
stuff with heat maps anyway check out
their docs they have a lot of really
cool stuff alright so now that we've
finished exploring our data it's time to
build our model our model is what's
called a supervised model so let's start
off by defining what a supervised model
is so you start off with some input in
this case we have our Wikipedia articles
as our input and this we call this our
training set so you also have some
labels for each piece of training data
and in our case our labels are the
languages so you might know how this
different differs from the k-means and
the pca algorithms that we ran before
they didn't use labels and that's the
difference between supervised and
unsupervised learning next you convert
your data to a numerical form then you
train your machine learning algorithm
using your vectorized training data and
the labels is input so this is often
referred to as fitting your model and at
this point you have a model that you can
take a new piece of unlabeled data and
predict the label alright so let's see
how this works in practice we call this
type again we call this type of
algorithm a classifier because you
provide some input and it classifies it
as one of multiple classes in the case
of our algorithm you provide some text
is input and it will classify the
language of the text to start off I've
defined a pipeline which combines a
tf-idf vectorize ER with an SVC
classifier and a pipeline is is just a
utility that allows you to build like a
multi-step classifier
the vector Iser converts the Wikipedia
articles into American and numerical
form and it does this by counting all
the combinations of n characters
character sequences in our data and
these are called n grams and after it
does does the counts then it applies
another algorithm called tf-idf and the
pipeline understands how to connect the
output of the vector Iser to the input
of the SVC algorithm so SVC is a
classification algorithm and it stands
for support vector classifier and it
takes numerical data as input into its
fit method and once fitted SVC can
predict the label of new data points and
again the pipeline understands how to
properly connect the output of our
vector Iser to the input of our
classifier so all that's left to do is
fit our data on our model let's look a
little closer at the these X train my
train that we're passing in so X train
going back to our previous diagram X
train is the portion of my data that I
set aside for training and it's an array
of text from our Wikipedia articles so
besides stripping out the wiki markup I
didn't do anything else to prepare the
data and again the vector eyes are
handles converting the text to the
numerical form that's required by the
SVC algorithm and white rain is the
labels of our training set so we start
off with this array called Y and this is
a one dimensional array and in this case
it contains the language of each article
unlike X train I do need to convert
these to a numerical form prior to
passing them to the fit method so we can
accomplish this using a label encoder
and label encoder will take our string
labels and convert them to numerical
category
so psychic learned comes with a ton of
algorithms building and many of them
have multiple parameters that you can
tweak and it can be a pretty daunting to
figure out which algorithm to use and
what values to pick for the parameters
so luckily there those tools built in
the psyche alert to help you tune your
models so you don't so that you can get
the best performance out of it so one
such tool is called randomized search CV
you give randomized search CV a range of
values to try for each parameter and
then it randomly chooses some values and
test them the other cool thing that
randomized search TV does for you is it
splits your training set into multiple
random chunks called folds and then it
uses a random set of these folds for for
training and another separate set for
testing the trained classifier and this
is what's called cross validation and
cross-validation helps you ensure that
your accurately measuring the
performance of your classifier so once
randomized search has completed you you
get the highest-scoring classifier along
with its score and the parameters so you
can easily run this kind of search on
multiple algorithms to figure out which
one will perform the best for your
particular data set and now that we have
our tune model it's time to validate its
accuracy so the metrics module in psyche
learn has several utility functions for
measuring measuring classifier
performance let's go through a few of my
favorites for the purposes of testing
the model I've excluded some data from
the training set generally speaking you
don't want to train an algorithm using
your full data set because many
algorithms can suffer from an issue
called overfilling and overfitting is
when you
your model is very good at making
predictions about your training set but
when presented with new data it performs
poorly all the metrics functions i'll
show you take two lists as input the
first why true it contains the correct
label for each sample in our in our
testing set and the second wipe red is
the predicted labels for each of our
samples and accuracy is pretty much what
it sounds like it's the overall
percentage of correct classifications so
96% isn't bad but can we do better
classification report builds a text
report showing the main classification
metrics ideally precision recall and f1
score should all have a value of one
with the worst possible value being zero
so and then the support column tells us
how many samples were in our test set
from each class so looking at the
classification report I can see right
away that there's something funny going
on with in this case the Bosnian
language and you might recall from
earlier from our explore phase that
Bosnian was really similar to a few
other languages so could this be
impacting our accuracy a good way to
find patterns in the incorrectly
classified data points is to use a
confusion matrix and here's what it
looks like for our classifier well
that's not really you very useful let's
visualize it okay so it's a little bit
better but you probably this probably
hard for you to read so let's have a
closer look at some of the more
interesting languages
alright so how do we interpret this so
you'll notice that each language shows
up once on the y-axis and again on the
x-axis and I'm not sure if you guys can
read this in the back but for example
Bosnian is on the first on the y axis
and the first on the x-axis and so they
intersect here so the the y-axis shows
the correct label the true label and the
x-axis shows the predicted label
anywhere where prediction is correct a
cell on the diagonal will have its
counter incremented and if the
prediction is incorrect a sell-off the
diagonal will have get its count
incremented so this is a heat map which
means that a hundred percent is
represented by the dark red and zero
percent is the dark blue so ideally we
should see nothing but dark red along
the diagonal and which would mean that
our predictions were one hundred percent
correct and then we'd see dark blue
everywhere else going along the rows we
can see exactly what each language is
being confused for so in this case we
can see that the language is BS hrs H
and s are are often being confused with
each other it turns out that these are
Bosnian creations serbo-croatian and
Serbian and these languages are almost
identical and they used to actually be
all be called serbo-croatian prior to
the Yugoslav wars so this gives us some
clues as to how we can improve our the
performance of our classifier according
to what I've read on Wikipedia these
languages are all the same so let's just
treat them as a single language for the
purposes of our language classifier okay
they noted no no this is a standard
confusion matrix is a standard Center
technique I didn't I didn't come up with
this yes and so combining the languages
that are the same together is pretty
straightforward all we have to do is go
back to where we created white rain and
anywhere where our labels where I one of
those BS hrs HS are just replace them
with a new label that we make up and
then we can rerun our random random
search and retrain our model so after
combining a bunch of these similar
languages were able to easily get over
ninety-nine percent accuracy and for
some of these languages if we really
wanted to distinguish them from one
another we could try attempting to train
more complex models just for them so
like we'd run that we'd make a
prediction using this model and then if
it's one of those languages then we'd
make another prediction using some more
complex model but before devoting too
much time into doing something like that
you should ask yourself if it's really
worth the effort and it all comes down
to your particular application all right
so that's all I got you can all go on
your LinkedIn profile and change your
titles to data scientists now a lot of
interesting stuff didn't make it into
this talk so i'll be posting some
follow-ups on my my blog and if you're
interested in receiving some email
updates when i post to my blog feel free
to hit me up after the Q&A and you can
sign up for my mailing list so any
questions
nothing come on guys
um I treated it as utf-8 I didn't run
into any any encoding issue is if that's
what you're asking but uh yeah I i think
i think it's utf-8 i didn't honestly do
a lot of digging there because it just
kind of worked so yeah sure sure so that
works really well for languages that
like have completely different
distributions of character sets but like
for like languages like the ones we were
having issues with like creation and
Bosnian and things like that like the
frequency is going to be extremely
similar if not like almost identical so
I'm well yeah just using just like
individual letter frequencies is not
going to be enough and that's why I like
if you look back way way way back when I
was turning the classifier I actually
chose an n-gram range of 2 comma 3
actually this is kind of this is an
older version of my some of my
classifier the current version i'm
running i think i'm just doing 2 grams
which is like combinations of to care of
every 2 character sequence and you you
can't you're only going to get i think
something around like 75 percent
accuracy looking at like single
characters for example
oh cool you said this insert one is
yours less my languages so in my case
like I was like classifying languages
that's so easy because I like write in a
text book that like all I needed to do
was use n grams right so in our case it
was like I had a bunch of texts as I
said like emails that our customers are
sending and we weren't always keeping
track of like the headers the encoding
headers that were being sent by their
like web clients so this was like kind
of like an easy way for me to get around
that issue of not having the data and
like figure out like what languages they
were actually using
we're email service providers so like we
provide like tools for email marketing
and stuff like that so so like people
can you know sign up for our service and
then we provide like some web interface
that allows them to like format their
the emails that they want to send and
like collect subscribers and well
surveymonkey i think i'm not sure like
everything that they yes yes though yeah
so MailChimp is Manship is one of our
competitors yeah yeah they have a lot of
advertising yeah sure so this is like
the distribution of the letter do we
still have time by the way I don't know
whose Nexus but oh really all right I
thought I only had a half an hour slot
all right cool so anyway yeah so what
we're seeing here is the distribution of
the letters i purposely didn't label the
y axis because I had to do something a
bit nasty here because they long story
short these these don't correspond 12 12
actual letter frequencies but but in any
case what we're comparing here is this
is the distribution of like letter
frequencies in this language and this is
the distribution of the letter
frequencies in this other language and
here's you can probably barely see it
but there's like a line here for the
25th percentile another line here for
the 50th percentile and on the line for
the 75th percentile we can see that like
for example these first two the
distributions line up pretty similarly
and the percentiles also line up pretty
similarly so the advantage is that you
actually get the distribution curve so
this this curve here is actually the
distribution curve is that
i think i'm using is just general like
completely outside of data science so
when you say the letter frequency you're
saying that in the middle there where
that line is there's a group of letters
that come up almost 50 or so I've heard
of her well yeah I mean it's probably
not fifty percent but like we can see
that like if I have if I was able to
label the axis like some some letter
here is coming up you know the most
frequently and another letter over over
here that is most likely the same letter
is in this for this language is also
coming up most frequently and like
somewhere up here is like the less least
frequent letter and somewhere down here
is exactly yeah no problem all right
thanks everybody